now these names might come out of
nowhere why would you ex
why would we call them these even an odd
well this is leading us to the next
section right what's in
a name this is the red function that i
showed you earlier which had even
symmetry and you might have thought to
yourself well how did i come up with
this function
how did i know that it would be
symmetrical well this is the actual
function
here it's a bit of a garbled mess i know
x squared minus x to the 4 and 6
i came up with this function because i
knew that it would give me
a function with reflection or symmetry
it's an
even function how did i know that now
there's kind of a clue here
in the name and if you have a look
closely at the function that i've given
you
it's not random have a look particularly
at the powers pay close attention to the
indices
you've got an x squared
you've got an x to the power of 4 and an
x to the power of
6. i knew that this would be an even
function
because all of the powers are
even and correspondingly we'll get to
this later on
to get an odd function i'm going to use
odd
powers now i can see quick examples of
this right if i just give you
let's suppose let f of x actually i just
used f of x so let's
come up with a new name let g of x equal
the simplest even function that most
people know about with an even power
is x squared let's test out our
algebraic
definition here if i go back and i say
well
if i've got even an even function it
should obey this thing here right
f of x should equal f of negative x so
i'm just going to test that out
i'm going to put in negative x
everywhere i saw
x so what happens well i'm going to do
my substitution
like so and i notice that negative x
squared is just negative x times
negative x so there are two negatives
there and they both
cancel leaving me with x times x this is
x squared in other words that's the
function that we started with g
of x and i got that function by doing g
of negative x so you can see that x
squared there
right because it's got an even power
it's always going to have those negative
factors cancelling out with each other
and we can prove this
for anything with an even power let's
suppose i had
h of x and it was something like
2 to the power of n where n is a whole
number
so i'm going to write that with some
fancy notation here which just means
n belongs to the set of numbers that are
all integers okay
now how would i go about proving that
this is also
going to be even well i'll do it in the
same way that i did it with that
function g of x
i'm going to test out h of negative x
okay what am i going to get here well
i'll do the substitution like so
and if you look closely at this i'm
going to use my index laws
i notice that that negative x is broken
up into a negative 1
and an x and they're raised to the power
2m well you can see here if i break
these two apart right i can say
i've got negative 1 to the power of 2n
and then i've got x to the power of
2n now this negative 1 on the end here
i can write it as negative 1
squared to the power of n there's the x
to the 2n
and you can see here no matter what n is
if n like if my
n was 3 then this would be x to the
power of 6. if my n
was 9 then i would have x to the power
of 18.
so you can see here no matter what value
of n you get that negative 1 squared is
just going to become
1. and 1 to the power of n will just be
1. so i'm just going to get x to the
power of 2n which
is the function that i started with h
of x so this is h of negative x and
these two are always going to be
identical now this is a proof for even
functions
i will leave it as an exercise for you
guys to have a go at what would happen
if
we had a function that was odd now in
order to have an odd function
i don't want the power to be 2n let's
see if i
call my function let's go u if u of x
was equal to
x to the power of 2 n plus 1
where n's a whole number you can see
whatever value of n you put in there if
i put in
like i tried n equals 3 before right
well this is going to give me a power of
if n equals 3 i'm going to get x to the
power of
6 plus 1 which is x to the power of 7.
so you can see there's an odd power
appearing so i'll leave it as an
exercise for you
to have a go at uh showing that if you
start with this guy
there we go you are always going to get
if you
test out u of negative x you are always
going to
get negative u of x
give that a go so what's in a name the
point is
that if you come up with even powers
you're going to have an even function
and if you come up with odd powers
you're going to get an odd function now
it's worth pointing out
that even though this is where the name
is based it's not only these kinds of
functions that have odd
or even symmetry for example a function
that we're pretty familiar with from
trigonometry
sine of x this has symmetry have a look
at it closely
what kind of symmetry does it have can
we reflect it across the y-axis would
you get the same thing
you wouldn't would you because you can
see that the the first
crest that you've got there it's not
going to line up to the right spot on
the
opposite side of the y axis this is not
reflection or symmetry
this is rotational symmetry so sine x
is an odd function there is though
another trigonometric function that
has even symmetry even though this one
has odd symmetry
if i gave you the other most common trig
function
cos x this guy
is a negative function can you see why i
can reflect this across the y-axis
and it's the same on both sides so even
though sine and cosine
are not polynomials they don't have
powers flying around or anything like
that
this is still an even function and we'll
return to this idea
a bit later on when we come to the
calculus section